good morning believe nation today's
message is be prepared over the use on
Jeeves II do so there's a big debate
where some people would say this not
much value in planning you need to react
very quickly yes you do need to react
very quickly there's no option to that
but there's a lot of value in
understanding potential scenarios and
being more prepared for them and then
being able to detect earlier which
scenario is working out so right now if
you're a car company with the oil prices
down volume of car shifts from the very
small cars - maybe the SUVs are actually
doing better and most car companies are
out of parts to be able to support the
volume for some of the larger vehicles
so it happens very quickly and if you're
not reacting fast then you're out of
luck but you can't just react you have
to prepare for scenarios right certain
reaction times just the lead times are
just not there to be able to react when
you see something happen this is an
interesting message and for me in
thinking about entrepreneurship it's not
just about planning multiple scenarios
and being able to react quickly to them
for me it's much more about having a
vision that you are ahead of the time
right your vision for the earth that you
want to create or the industry that you
want to mold is ahead of the time right
now you're planning to get there and so
for me when you get there you've already
been planning for it it's already
expected like it's already happened in
your head because you've been preparing
for these years so for example one of my
goals is I have a million subscribers on
the YouTube channel one of my goals is I
want to help a billion entrepreneurs I'm
going to be doing interviews with
successful and famous entrepreneurs
about their success I want to have
Taylor Swift come and learn Saul set at
Toronto dine salsa right I have these
big goals these visions that
most people think are crazy but as they
get close to the happening I'm prepared
for them because I've been preparing for
the past year-plus to make that happen
right a million subscribers on my
channel in my head has already happened
I've already seen the path to get there
and the path will deviate but when I get
there it's not gonna be a surprise like
oh I don't have enough people to help me
get there or I don't have enough videos
to keep this channel going right I'm
building the machine right now and so
when that future happens it's not a
shock it's not a surprise there's
something to really react to because I
already had the vision for it and I
think that's what the best entrepreneurs
do is you have a vision for a world that
does not exist yet and you go out and
create it and you're helping build that
future that nobody else maybe sees and
so when it happens you're best prepared
to leverage it because you were creating
it right you've been spending years
already building it up in your head and
taking the actions every single day to
make that future happen so you're best
prepared to capitalize on it and I think
that's just the one difference that I
believe then from what's in that video
so I'd love to know you guys have to
think though is is being prepared about
having a vision and working towards it
or is it just being able to be quick to
react to the market based on different
scenarios you guys weigh in let me know
you think that's the question of the day
leave it in the comments below I'll join
in the discussion thank you so much for
watching have an amazing day continue to
believe and I'll see you again tomorrow
morning for another shot of espresso